oh
hyperactif
généreux
ce serait un père noël bonjour bienvenue
chez nous bien venu un lézard d'ici
willy fontaine ou présidents
d'associations
quand
pour l'instant on fait des moyens du
bord la dame elle est on va dire
professionnels du maquillage mais
aujourd'hui bénévole
jamais les enfants les personnes j'aime
pas voir la souffrance sur sur le visage
des personnes donc
j'essaye d'apporter
une partie de moi est que ce soit par un
maquillage par des activités et à porter
à sourire en fait voilà parfois les
personnes en difficulté sont en
souffrance sociale financière familiale
notre combat c'est de faire en sorte que
des actions culturelles qu'on fédère les
artistes des gens donner le maximum de
personnes et qu'on a un peu lisse des
actions solidaires
voilà avec des jeunes une action très
symbolique très la fédé m'a vraiment de
bonnes actions d'associations
c'est un petit marc maltais par nicolas
mais autant la paix linge ou à la radio
et puis mes appels la mamie dont elle
est l'amie des sites d'organismes
conférence de presse j'étais en une
semaine
conférence de presse tout d'organiser un
concert elle soit on remet 5000 euros
par an pour accompagner l'enfant en
métropole
donc ces moments là aujourd'hui ses
parents sont devenus des membres et des
bénévoles de l'association l'huile à 14
ans ils permettront temps nicolas
m'effraye un coq ou d'ailleurs
une maman fait donc c'est elle qui fait
les on va dire que c'est mon attitude
on la découvre en fait par le fait de
faire ces actions que c'est aussi une
forme de thérapie pour moi touche du
bois mais voilà sa vache est en pleine
forme j'ai eu des problèmes de santé
j'ai traversé des moments assez
douloureux - ma traversée meilan alan
gold en août et les shows de wau temps
grâce à un petit peu moins de recruter
mais pas nos racines
voilà ma petite soeur 1 2 tasse histoire
de encore là 12 en huit différence donc
voila mais moi je les touche reconnu
comme s'approche des gens prêts à aider
les champs comment ça se fait que les
gens le suis je pense que c'est la façon
dont ils abordent les champs
là aussi on quand il parle de ça on voit
on voit dans ses yeux qui qu'il aime ça
qu'ils aiment faire ce que je fais
okani de la pédiatrie et nous vient en
fait que apprendre à porter un petit
moment de joie il sait ce que c'est un
enfant hospitalisé en pédiatrie donc et
vous dis bien avec le choeur grand
ouvert pour apporter du sourire aux
enfants aux personnels et c'est vrai que
ça un moment d'évasion pour nous pour
les enfants de dettes dans le soin mais
dans le soin autrement pour les enfants
e
et nous ce qu'on essaie de faire à côté
des professionnels qui sont là pour
former ces jeunes c'est d'apporter un
côté on va dire la passion enfin ce
souffle ce sont des élèves du collège
des deux canaux donc son partenaire
vasseur là ce sont des artistes et elles
font partie d'une association de décor
il appelle les colibris
bonjour il ya deux façons de prévenir la
violence il ya ceux qui font la
remédiation après et puis il ya aussi
traité en avant en amont créé ces petits
instants de bonheur et élèves viennent
s'inscrire justement dans ces moments de
solidarité donc elles viennent
elles ont préparé des choses en amont
elle vient de près ce moment partagé
puis donner de leur temps ne donnent pas
200 personnes même si chacun sait pour
un petit moment
juste un bonjour wade voulait pas facile
de faire le pas mais c'est juste ça
c'est pour un petit moment
des fois il se dit athée aujourd'hui
c'est l'hymne de même peut-être chez moi
won his que des mois on est fiers en
place jusqu'aux derniers battements de
mains entre ses rivaux tels blatter il
faut revenir à de l'humain donc il faut
revenir à du lien à ce cette enquête est
né en suisse et moment qu'on passe
ensemble est à noter réunionnais
réunionnais la donne un mot la réunion
donc il faut pas nous nous la demande va
lyonnais voilà le quotidien
merci merci beaucoup ça
on